so hello everybody i am here with
frederica matthews green many of you
probably have heard of her have seen her
she really is a
famous author she has written several
books she is involved
in many causes she is really a light in
the pro-life movement she has been
involved also just as
as a upstanding christian woman that has
been given uh
ways for for women and for people to see
how we can live our life
as christians in the modern world she is
also very involved in ancient faith as
well
uh has written many blogs she's just all
over the place if you just google her
you will see
that she has done many many things and
so i'm very happy
to have uh have her with us we're going
to talk a little bit about
you know how it is as people that we can
reengage the world with meaning
uh that we can kind of rediscover the
shining aspect of the world
how we can do that and and i know she's
got great insight about that
so frederica this this discussion kind
of started
it's almost humorous because someone
pointed me to a facebook post that you
made which was kind of like a little
rant about the term re-enchantment
and how you didn't like that term and
it's true that we've been using that
term like myself father andrew many
people have kind of been using that term
and so i thought it was it was a little
it's probably a good place to start
maybe you can tell us
a little bit why it isn't that word
bothers you and hopefully that'll be a
springboard for uh for a deeper
discussion
sure yeah i think it probably will be i
um
i was just noticing that as much as i
sympathize with
the goal of re-enchantment and as much
as i
i was very heartened by you
saying that it's inevitable actually
it's reality you know people got to
return to reality eventually
but i didn't like the term i noticed i
was avoiding
using the term and i thought why so
um yes i i did intend to be a humorous
not a serious
challenge my objective was that
i think the ultimate objection is it
focuses on the world that needs to
change rather than
we need to change but the term
suggests that god created the world and
then he enchanted it in a separate step
and that somehow it became
disenchanted and now we need to find the
power somehow to re-enchant it i just
questioned almost every step in that
range there
yeah it's almost as if it's as if it's
our role to kind of
put the magic back into the world you
know rather than
uh like you said like you suggested in
the post which is to
transform our own selves our own
relationship with god and that
the the transformation the change in the
way that we perceive the world is almost
going to happen
on its own let's say once that happens
yes i've
long felt that when the time came that
christians were losing the right to
speak
in the public square that we would see a
resurgence of miracles
and that also would be very important
for each person to know how to tell the
story
of your own life in christ and the
things you've seen
god do in your life because we need to
be able to tell our story
you know at 20 or 30 years ago it was
all about having our
our our objective um uh arguments
in line you know our apologetics we
needed to be able to argue our cause
logically
time is over and we need to be humble
and we need to rehearse it give it a try
think through what what would your story
be
if you're giving a elevator talk to a
non-christian
what story would you tell them yeah well
i think so i'm going to make my pitch
for the word for the word
just to start us off and then we can go
on but wrong
wrong this is this is this is this is
the pitch that i'm making okay
is it it really is in the the meaning of
the word like almost the etymology of
the word which is that
that one of the aspects of modernity or
the modern world has been to make us
believe
that the world doesn't have it's not a
song that the word that the world is not
a pattern it's not a poem
that it's kind of this weird arbitrary
uh
you know layout of uh facts that have
you know like billiard balls that hit
each other and that have no
meaning to them and that meaning is
actually uh
put back on top of the world and so in a
way the way that i kind of view the term
enchantment is almost the opposite of
how you described it which is
is rather kind of reliving the fact that
the world is
actually a pattern that it is a song
it's a dance it's a story
and that we need to dive back into
stories and the example you gave about
about let's say um being capable
of telling a good story the good story
of your own
life the good story of your own
encounter with others and with christ
and with the saints
that's exactly what i'm talking about in
a way that's like and that not just tell
it but really kind of live the world
as a story rather than you know this
kind of cold
uh arbitrary world that that a lot of
the let's say the materialists have
wanted us to believe
the world is so that's my that's my
pitch for the word
i i i get now um the thing about singing
a song because chant in french is
literally song
so the world has been has a song in it
it is within a song in chat and
um we need to participate in that mostly
that's what we need to do
recognize that this is reality
and then find a way to to sing our part
in that song
to bring that that hymn of worship to
life
in the world yeah but i think that
you're you're
i think that the the let's say the
resistance you have is is appropriate in
the sense
of especially i think some of the images
people were posting on the facebook
post were the best ones which is you
know mickey mouse as the sorcerer
who is like enchanting the the brooms
and everything
and i think that's a perfect image to
show the difficulty of how people tend
to understand it
which is almost in really in the magical
in the bad aspect which is that we as
people have the power
to impose a narrative on the world and
this is actually something that we've
seen happen
more and more in social media and just
regular media where
there's a kind of wizard aspect where
you see people trying to force a story
on reality
and try to to make us believe things
which are actually just this kind of
imposed
uh reorganized things in a in an
actually dishonest way
to make us see a pattern uh forcefully
and i think that that really is the
difficulty and
as christians we need to really discover
the true
the true pattern the true song which is
there in the world rather than
as using human power to just kind of
impose
these narratives on on the world so
that's that's kind of how i see it
you know what i i think is is true is
that the
the real pattern the true pattern is
embedded in
reality and we are definitely being um
threatened and even coerced by stories
that are not true
um like in the us the story that the
whole country was
founded in order to spread slavery
um it's it's just not true it's a
heartbreaking story maybe you can tell
is this story true or not is does it
create
hope does it create joy and wonder
does it make you love other people or
does it make you hate them
um there's some really elementary sorts
of tests we can use
to find out whether or not this is a
true story a true song
yeah and also true stories have many
sides that say i i've been trying to
help people see that for example
some of the great epics you know like
the trojan uh like the epics of the
trojan war like the iliad
there's a way in which you can actually
sympathize with all the different sides
of the of the story even in a conflict
like there's a there isn't just this
simple demonizing
uh of of the other but really a way in
which
a way in which these the different
elements of the story kind of
point to something bigger than what they
are and those have been always been the
great stories you know and
and the simple stories are those where
you know it's
it's it's so simple and clear especially
in these
the uh the modern political narratives
like okay they're the bad guys
we just need to destroy them and then
everything will be fine
yeah i was going to ask you if you've
seen uh timothy patitz's book the ethics
of beauty
and it begins with the story of the
iliad the odyssey
and um he proposes that what used to
happen
is soldiers would gather and over the
course of several days someone would
sing
this long story to them and it had the
effect of healing trauma
that that really was the kind of therapy
to be first in this story where there
are good people and bad people and
good people do bad things sometimes and
there's
death it's a very ultimate story
and hearing this beautiful song uh was a
way to reorient themselves to a reality
that had been
chaotic and terrifying and to help them
find
that that place of a kind of an eternal
beauty of their own story
fits into an eternal song
so i do recommend um the book it's dr
timothy
yes he's been on my channel before yeah
and we had a wonderful
we had a wonderful discussion about uh
you know beauty as
being really the foundation of of
reality and i think as
in the iliad especially there are some
scenes which do they really do seem to
do
exactly that you know the meeting with
the trojan king to
negotiate the body of his son is such
a intense moment of
of of almost even though it's said from
told from the greek side there is this
deep compassion even for your enemy
and and kind of recognizing that he's
still my enemy and there's this anger
and all of this is kind of going through
and there's no justification
of the the moral decisions that are made
it's just this this this
this participation in the difficult and
painful story
and i think i agree that that would
definitely be something which
if we understand it that way that it can
that he could play a kind of healing
role
um and i think that's what the
crucifixion is is ultimately really what
that leads to you know when you look at
our services uh
during holy week the intensity
of the mourning but also this this idea
that we in a way are also those that
crucify
christ but that we're also mourning him
and that we also
wish hope for his resurrection all of
this kind of this jumble of
of pain and hope and uh and and even to
a certain extent guilt but it's all kind
of coming together towards this movement
where it will be you know resolved in
the resurrection
i wonder why it's so hard to tell the
christian story in a
post-christian environment because i
think what people
what non-christians expect the christian
story to be
is simplistic and sunny and artificially
optimistic
and that the happy ending is already is
pre-assumed before you begin the story
in a way that is true we do believe
there's an ultimate happy ending
it's not in question but the expectation
is that christianity is a shallow thing
and i i don't really know how we um
how we approach that yeah it is offered
as a very shallow thing
by by christians in america i can speak
for my own country it's been simplified
down to just
a few words how you how you can be saved
yeah and i think that participation is
really the only way to
experience that you know when you go
through the services of lamentation
you know they're long and and and you
kind of
you get into this mode of you're tired
and you're
but you're listening to these these
amazing uh songs
of lamentation and then these little
glimpses of
call to resurrection like kind of
intersperse in the lamentations
and so you really you really almost do
feel like you're going through
a morning which is leading to to healing
at the end
but it's not it's not like uh just
surfing over the pain or surfing over
the trauma it really is diving into it
but
then giving these little this like
punctual uh hope that keeps growing and
growing as we get to holy saturday and
then finally
kind of explodes into the resurrection
i just learned something too from people
on my facebook group that
i've never heard this before and i want
to ask if you had
about the crotalus which is at that
friday night service people would have
little
wooden gadgets that would make a
clacking or knocking noise a rattle
really yeah and if they say it's because
in the west you weren't allowed to ring
any bells between
thursday thursday evening and saturday
morning
so in order to do the things that
alderbells would do
they had these little placards this is
on holy friday
yeah on holy friday and um but the thing
is that cretalis is a greek word
and so i think it was brought over from
the
the orthodox practice and somebody wrote
in and said
he was visiting a ukrainian orthodox
church in canada
and they had like a whole box of these
little wooden noisemakers that he said
he thought they were probably a century
old
so um it's an interesting way that we
bring
not music but sound you know we're
inserting something that
may not be a beautiful sound but we're
amplifying the experience
through extra means through the through
incense through music through the light
everything that's going on
it's a full body experience yeah but it
could be the it could be especially if
it's on holy friday it could actually be
about death
and because noise noise is usually
related to
to death like if you if you think of uh
how
or the end it's related to the end you
see it in purim festivals for example
these noise makers are used in in purim
and it's a spinning like a spinning
noise you know
and it seemed it might have to do with
uh with a kind of
the carnival aspect of the crucifixion
where where
the crucifixion has everything in it so
there is an aspect of the crucifixion
which is like the end of a world like
this end and then
this kind of moving into a new beginning
at the same time
that that that could possibly be why but
i'm really surprised to hear that i'm
actually kind of excited to know that
that exists yeah
yeah and this and they're very beautiful
you know what you find they're very
beautifully carved
um yeah it's another train of thought
worth uh worth it's worth exploring
and so a lot of your work has been uh i
think about this
kind of helping modern americans modern
christians
modern even secular people try to plunge
back
into into a world of meaning you know
and so what are what is some of the
advice you you give to people to help
them
reconnect to to this meaningful world
there's always a dilemma
and you know this is an orthodox
christian of um
wanting to offer people the small bits
of
the you know tradition
that they are willing to take on and
what hope will be a more complete
journey
um offering these these little things
that perhaps they can comprehend
even before they're totally on board
with everything and yet you know that by
taking a small piece out you're giving
them something artificial
i always felt that way even in my
episcopalian days
when i was in episcopal seminary in the
70s all of a sudden there was this new
hymn it was a very ancient hymn it was
used in the early
church and it was like it had been just
rediscovered
and the hymn is holy god holy
holy immortal have mercy on us and as
you know we
we use this hymn a great deal yeah all
that's every day
it's in every libertarian service and in
our daily
daily prayers but at the time i was like
wow there's really something
different about that prayer it sounds
more like a chant
it sounds more like an incantation
to spin around on enchant incantation as
if
god is present when you say these words
and my thought was
why haven't we been using this all along
if we know what the hymns and the
prayers of the early church are
the the visual arts of the early church
if these things are still known
why were they ever abandoned and to
bring it back in as this little
wrapped up box you know that you can
open up well that was pleasant and now
we go back
and we move over and then we move on to
something else i had the same experience
once in
in my church you know god bless him my
pastor had met some romanian protestants
who were still doing
uh would still say christ is risen pasca
and then with the answer
and so he tried to get the baptist
church to do that
and it was just like this half this half
thing and people were like what is this
thing like what is going on
uh and so like you said it it didn't it
didn't have the kind of integrated or
kind of uh
it ended up being a very superficial uh
part but what you said about invocation
or incantation
i think is a very powerful insight that
you have
about the difference the notion
a type of way of seeing the world you
know this this capacity to invoke
and to like in the jesus prayer you have
the same the same
movement you know where you kind of
invoke the name and then there's this
participation
in you know in another person by kind of
calling them let's say
and this is something which which is
actually so it's
it's so intuitively right when we think
about it just
for a moment but we've completely lost
these types of practices
i remember um the little book by father
roman braga
a transcribed interview called um the
the interior universe exploring the
entire interior universe something like
that
um but he said at one point a jesuit
priest asked him how many times do i
have to say the jesus prayer
before i can see the the uncreated it's
hilarious
yeah yeah you're missing uh missing the
point there my friend
father roman said i told him do not say
that prayer anymore
oh man going for the jugular
and you just completely yeah just stop
stop
yeah yeah yeah you could have a software
running that
just says it like automatically and then
like it could be on a loop
then they're like like prayer spinners
they use exactly
yeah yeah just put it on the loop and
get get enough
up to 5 000. this is great now you know
um but i thought too i've been thinking
a lot about
um the way education teaches us to deal
in abstractions
and kind of from early childhood we are
taught to think in
abstract terms i've been reading
this are you familiar with this book
cognitive development
or um how about this is the predecessor
for many people orality
and literacy by walter ahn
[Music]
um this is interesting because it's the
results of
the work of a neuropsychologist
communist soviet neuroscientist really
wow
in the 1930s so it's like
but he went to these little towns in
uzbekistan and kazakhstan and he
interviewed people who were
it was like a spectrum some of them had
had begun
to become literate and most had not
and some were high in the social status
some were low he just interviewed a lot
of people and asked them questions
and when he said um i was going to
he was going to um ask them he showed
them
abstract images just a circle a square
a triangle asked what they were and
those who had a little bit of um
education would say
that's a circle that's a triangle
the people who were illiterate would say
that's a mirror
that's a house
um they recognized them as friends
innocence
as as things they already knew these
things are
part of the story of their lives
that they are participating in a story
with all these other people
and they are enmeshed in all these these
uh uh touchable tangible things around
them
it seemed to me it did not seem that way
to the author
it did not seem to him that this was a
good thing okay
you know we have to train them so
they'll think logically and abstractly
and
um it intrigued me how he missed that
they were capable of using
abstract categorical thinking he would
show them
uh if four images there's a saw a
hatchet a hammer
and a log and he'd say which one doesn't
belong
and of course the right answer just say
the law doesn't belong
nobody would say that they would all say
you have to have the log
or there's nothing for the saw and the
hammer to do
to work on that's theirs the loudest
part of the story
and we'd say you know a house in a
wheelbarrow and a tree and a bird you
know well the bird is the only one
that's
that's a living animal they say no you
need the bird the bird will make a nest
in the tree and it will be next to the
house look it's next to the house
and he will sing and people in the house
will be happy
they just really resisting resisted
reducing things to abstraction
and i think maybe that's the sickness
that we have and one more thing as he
gets further along he has like nine
stages he takes them through
one of the last things he does is he
says um tell me about yourself
what are you like what kind of a person
some people are angry some people are
happy
what kind of a person are you and they
would resist that and they would say
you have to ask the people who know me
how can i how can i know my own heart
but they know me
they can tell you what i'm like i think
the sense of being enmeshed in a story
in a world where there are people who
know you better than you know yourself
you don't define yourself you don't make
up your own profile
it is the circle of others around you
who really know you
i think this is what people are hungry
for but they don't know it
and we are so heavily conditioned to
think
in terms of abstractions um one of them
was a
a spectacle a drinking glass a water
pitcher
and uh um oh what was the last one i
don't remember
but there were one of them that just
didn't fit then the man said
you can buy them all in a shop so
you know he was capable of thinking in
abstract terms but
yeah but it was real life that mattered
yeah they didn't they were
they tended when presented with a series
of things they tended
rather than try to find the excluded one
try try to
to web to weave them together into a
story they actually tried to see how
they communed with each other rather
than the opposite which is which is one
of the diseases of the
the modern world like we we understand
health through disease we understand
things through their
exceptions things through that we try to
we i almost have like an upside down way
of understanding the world
where we look at we look at we look at
things that
don't work in order to understand things
that work and that's how we kind of
we tend to we tend to analyze reality
and in terms of
this idea of self-naming this is if
there's any disease that we have
it's self-naming the whole individual
idea of
you know and this we kind of have a
caricature of the will to power right
now in in our society where people
can just declare themselves to be
whatever they fancy themselves to be
and not understand that your identity is
actually like you said is supposed to be
enmeshed
within a uh you know a network of human
relations
and if it's not then whatever identity
you kind of self-proclaim
it's going to make you miserable no
matter what it is because we're meant
for communion we're not meant to be
these splendid
uh individuals in isolation and kind of
declaring our
our identity to others you know the
temptation of autonomy
and it really that's the sin it's like
that's the sin of satan it's the sin of
adam it's the sin
it's the main sin is the sin of trying
to be autonomous and to to kind of be on
top of things and not
you know it's the it's actually that's
the that's the the first sin and then
the other sins kind of come after you
know all the what we
tend to think as sins you know you know
what i i one thing i noticed
in giving speeches and giving talks um
because i don't always
talk about orthodoxy sometimes i'm
talking about
social things or sex and sexuality or
pro-life obviously
um i noticed that there was one word if
i said it the audience would stop
breathing
and they would just freeze and
after a few times i realized it was
really consistent
and the word was loneliness that if i
mentioned
loneliness it was like people would and
it was like they were thinking
how did she know my secret
loneliness yeah yeah and you know i'm
always encouraging people if you're
young marry young
get married at 18 19 20. start having
kids right away
um i sure opposed that when my son was
19
and got married i thought that wasn't a
good idea well now he's they're
expecting their ninth
child his wife always wanted a big
family and she's got one
and it's just so much healthier than the
autonomy that
goes on and on and on and you marry at
30 and then you're trying to have
children at 35 and
yeah we have an artificial idea of how
possible that that is
exactly bent and always be bent
to do the things we want i think the
appeal of autonomy when you're young
is almost overwhelming and perhaps it's
natural to some extent you need to
define yourself
as separate from mother and father and
you need to set up your own little home
in our modern culture
where where youth extends into the
middle 30s
what happens is that autonomy can work
very well when you're young
and attractive and sexy and not fat
and you know there's so many things you
have going for you
but everybody gets older and every year
a new
crop of 20 year olds is rolling off
their belts you know exactly and you're
25 and 30 and 35 and 40.
and you're competing with them too yeah
exactly and so
the world keeps saying you know be young
and sexy and independent and autonomous
but they don't show us the ones who are
40 and 50 and 60
and never married and are facing perhaps
in their old age being cared for in a
old people's home
where the people don't take jobs there
because they love old people
you know they it's not necessarily a
pleasant or even a safe
place to end your life um so we've
we've seduced our culture has seduced
people
by these images of images of how great
it is when you're young
and piggybacking maybe on what is to
some extent a natural and healthy desire
when you're young and covering up and
hiding from us
the loneliness that sets in my drama
yeah exactly
i think i think that that's that's
that's so right
and i i see it myself because i like we
were we were
of those that you know i married pretty
young like not i'm married at 23
and then but we started having children
later
you know we waited quite a while and and
it's it's only
it's only when you're your 40s you're in
your 40s and
you know your third child is young and
you realize that
you don't have the same energy that you
did and you don't have the same kind of
voice-ness that you did
and you think wow you know this would
have been
like to all those moments in my 20s that
i'd barely remember
i mean i remember them but they don't
have the vibrancy
of the time that i spent with my son
when he was two
like they don't have that vibrancy and
so so i mean i don't say i would say
that i regret because i don't like i
don't kind of like
live that way but i i can understand why
it probably would have been a better
idea
you know to to really kind of
consolidate that that
that that because now like our family is
it is an amazing
uh microcosm like we love being with
each other we love spending time
together you know when we're at the
dinner table everything is nice and
it's it's a nice time but it's you think
oh wait that could have been
we could have had more of that and also
longer
uh so anyway so yeah i i would encourage
people to
to kind of break the norm and not agree
don't let people seduce you thinking oh
you're in school you have to finish your
school
you have to get your phd and then you're
you know you're 26 or whatever
that's that's a lie i wrote an essay
once that i titled
let's have more teen pregnancy
that's amazing no i know it was it was
almost accepted by the new york times
it's just like you know just by an inch
but it was published in national review
so um but that was my thesis that it's
good to marry young and to begin having
children young
but i said you have to let go of there
are three things you want
and you have to let go of one of them
one is both of you are going to college
at the same time
yeah another is you are living
independently of your parents
you might have to live in your parents
basement for a while and
um the third has to do with timing
children
that that's if you want to live in your
own home and go to college at the same
time
both in college then what about having
kids that makes it much more difficult
the way our culture is threatened
apparently
so yeah and and there's something
there's something about being poor which
people nobody accepts like nobody wants
to be poor but
it's actually being poor is not that bad
if you accept it
i mean i don't mean like poor in the
sense you don't have anything to eat but
just being just living in an i like we
like we were poor for quite i would say
like now we're doing fine but we were
poor for a very long time and
we just accepted it and it actually
meant it made us free we could do
a lot of things because we didn't have
this
thing pressing on us that we kind of
need to prove to everybody that we have
a new car
that we have a shiny this and shiny that
was just it's actually easier to be poor
in our world today than maybe it's ever
been in the history of
of humanity so so i would say to not see
that as a
idea of like making all your money in
your in your 20s and 30s i don't see
that
that's that's not necessary we did that
when um
i was 21 when we got married that was
just a week out of college
and i had our first baby and when i was
25
my husband was 30 now 28 something like
that
and um we decided that we were going to
live within his income
as a junior pastor which is very small
of course
and one of the decisions we made was
looking up all the dietetic and
nutritional information
we raised our children on powdered milk
instead of buying a bottle of milk we
would buy powdered milk and mix it with
water and
big brown picture in the kitchen and
they grew up with that so they accepted
that
um i remember uh we would go every week
to mcdonald's for lunch with my my two
friends and their two little daughters
the same age
when my daughter was a toddler they
would buy
dinners or buy lunches for themselves
and their children
and i would bring a sandwich and drink
water
and my daughter would have a plain
hamburger and nothing else on the side
this is before happy meals
yeah um so it's possible it's possible
even when your friends have a lot more
money
um you can you can live within your
budget yeah
well it's all but it you have to accept
it because
bitterness can set in you know if you're
not careful and you
you're if you if you do it out of kind
of resentment and frustration it's not
it's not going to work but if you just
accept it
then it's actually quite freeing to live
that way i could never have become an
icon carver if i hadn't if both my wife
and i
had not decided that it was totally fine
to be poor and to
have an old beat up car and to you know
not fix the windows because they should
be fixed but they can still survive for
another few years and
you know that kind of stuff you just
think you just accept it and then
then you're free to do things that a lot
of people wish they could do and then
they don't
i i felt like i actually got a kick out
of it
i felt like outsmarting someone you know
that's wonderful madison avenue and all
these other things and just
looking and looking for the cheapest
possible way to do things
and my kids get into the spirit of it i
taught them when they saw
advertisements because we used to watch
regular broadcast television as a family
when the advertisement came to the end i
would say and what was the lie
can you spot the lie and and so i train
them always to look for the lie
in any advertising where are they trying
to trick you or to lure you in
yeah well they're trying to convince you
that that you know if you only you had
this then
everything would be okay it would be
perfect
so i i think we're talking in um you
know around the same thing over and over
again but
for me the big thing about orthodoxy is
that it has
um that that sense of being embodied and
embedded and that we are part of an
ancient story
and that me as an individual human
i don't matter as a if i'm plucked out
of the context
and put on another planet or something
that i am part of a community
and that i try to help that community
and i get so much help from
the community and from their support and
their prayers
um we are all embedded here all together
and i know that if i get older
and i get dementia and i'm failing in
other ways and i'm failing physically i
know there are people who love me
there are people who will take care of
me i'm uh
my the next baby will be 15
grandchildren
we had three our oldest had three our
youngest had three but
that went in the middle is they're
getting their ninth
i feel so embedded in a loving community
that i don't fear
i don't fear death i i know i know that
i belong
and the the myth of autonomy
i think is what's breaking the heart of
our fellow humans in america
many of our fellow christians as well
when i look at the things that orthodoxy
offers when i look at the things that
converts say about
what they like about orthodoxy it's
always
i'm going to move my eyes over here
because i've got a document here
i never learned how to share screens
it's okay i have to have a grandchild
tell me how to do this
but the list of what people say when
they become orthodox
you're thrown in the deep end you just
have to live it
it's like they can't describe it direct
contact
it's dynamic you have to come and see
firsthand alive immediacy
i find that's the term i use the most
it's the quality of
it's just in your face it's immediate
it's right there
you have to be there organic
good old warren farhat i asked him what
is the one word you'd use to describe
orthodoxy he said
organic just sums up so much yeah
body immersion you have to experience it
you marinate it's active it involves all
the senses
yeah but that that i think that's also
it's all these words are
are good to help people understand too
like the idea of marinating is good
because
we are so used to kind of immediate
satisfaction
that it's true that some people you know
at first when they they kind of come to
the services
like what is happening you know i don't
know like again and again and again and
again and they don't know
like where these prayers are going that
seems to be just like you said thrown in
the deep end
where where at first their needs you
need time to kind of soak in
and and and kind of acclimatize and just
slowly start to
see the patterns but not in a mental way
but really kind of all suddenly trying
to be inside the pattern
and at some point sometimes you're not
even thinking about it because you you
you hear the prayers and the para the
prayers do have a pattern
and then you know where it's going but
you're not even thinking about it you
kind of know what is happening and what
it's going
and then it slowly starts to uh it
slowly starts to become a
a background pattern to to to your
perception but it does
it doesn't happen immediately you can't
just like go to a service and all of a
sudden you're like okay i get it
i get it i get it i get it it doesn't
work that way oh boy
yeah my first reaction to an orthodox
service was it was weird
and boring and i want to get out of here
you know just
really and it's strangely formal and
informal at the same time
it looks super organized but messy
really messy and
these kids crawl crawling around and and
it's like it looks sometimes like the
priest knows what he's doing but
sometimes it feels like no one knows
what they're doing
but it's it's it's like it's it's funny
to it's hard to describe that to people
it's kind of strange sense of formality
and informality which is all happening
at the same time
that is so true i've i've tried in
talking about
tradition because we're such a negative
picture of what tradition means
this i think instead about christmas
traditions
and now your christmas traditions you do
them because you like them
because they're fulfilling somehow and
they met the family together
but you do them because they work the
orthodox traditions
work in that sense they have an effect
and you can't learn them all at once
that if you married into a family that
has lots and lots of numbers
lots and lots of christmas traditions
you wouldn't get at all
the first christmas it would take
repeating
and i say imagine they have red and
green napkins they're doing that very
faded but they use them every year
and you might notice that last year
grandpa got a red one but this year he
got a green one
you might say oh you've broken your
tradition
what you don't know is there's a
tradition about the traditions
yeah you know there's there's something
that when you've marinated in it
you kind of know instinctively where
things are little t
and where things are big t it's um
you really can't learn it except by
doing it so that's kind of the mystery
about orthodoxy
people who are in it tend to smile a lot
and they're very happy with
it but it's because they can feel it
going to work
on them they can feel how it's changing
them inside
and making them more and more like the
heroes that we have
there's so many 20th century heroes
of the faith that we want to emulate and
be like it's like having baseball pic
pictures you know posters on the walls
of your bedroom and just
wishing you could be like them or you
want to hold the bat the way your hero
holds the bat
it's a wonderful family to be in yeah
you really don't
realize that at first and there's
something about the causality which is
also sometimes difficult to understand
especially in our kind of psychological
psychologized world where let's say
people are struggling with
a passion or struggling with a sin or
struggling with something and they're
like well how do i fight this like how
do i
how do i deal with this problem in my
life and they wanted like a direct
road where they could just do these
simple things
and then they'll get through their
problem uh but
in in the kind of the orthodox tradition
in faith it's
it's like this whole process where as
you improve your prayer life as you are
more involved as you
as you remind yourself of god during the
day as you do the jesus prayer and your
little moments
all of this is working and at some point
you're like oh
you know that passion that i had all of
a sudden it's like cut in half or
you know that this thing that i was
doing before this bad habit it's like
okay
it's gone and i don't even know where i
got the will
to to do that it didn't come from me
it's just this
this kind of this healing process that
just kind of flows through you so
yeah it's difficult to describe that to
modern people because they want
the solution like i have a problem give
me the pill this is what i need to take
to do this and it doesn't work that way
another part of that illusion i think is
that they
they they say you know people who are
functioning under a high level of
traditions
well it makes you all be alike it makes
you all be little carbon copied
you know figures but it's actually the
reverse when they want that
that program that will fix them they
want something that might be useful to a
million people and they could just get
in line and go through the steps and it
would fix things
orthodoxy is more radically
individualistic than that
that the program that works on you is
finding you at your deepest levels at
your most
unique level and it addresses you in a
wholly unique way you're not one in the
line of a million people using a program
you went in a line of one and god knows
you
so much better than you know yourself
yeah and because it's so there's so much
like
i've noticed that like sometimes i've
noticed for example like my attachment
to certain saints for example
i can't completely explain it i can't i
can't tell you why
that i feel closer to this or that saint
uh but i can see it working in my life
like i can see that that communion that
i'm
that i'm living with is slowly changing
me and transforming me and making me
closer to
to in close to the image of christ and
so it's like that for so many things
because
even the practices you can have in the
church there's so there's so many
that you unless you're like a monk you
know you can't do them all so you end up
through your discussion with your
spiritual father through all this you
end up
finding uh something which looks like
like you or you moving towards god you
could say something like that yeah
we we are tiptoeing up to the question
of the supernatural
which is that simultaneously a very
difficult
thing to get across but also something
that
um non-christian non-believers the nuns
crave they crave that and that's why
it's all about
um you know are there little spells or
little charms you can cast on people or
their potions
is this a haunted house um they have a
lot of
what they probably don't realize is an
unhealthy attraction
to the supernatural and they don't
understand that it is a dangerous world
and
that in christianity you can do that
safely
and supernatural things do happen yeah
part of telling our story
is to say when this incredible you know
like
the time that um we were trying to vote
on who our patron saint would be
for the women's group and saint nina
kept pushing her way
over and over and over again none of us
knew who
she was uh the that one person began
reading a short biography the president
of the women's
uh association with sisterhood began to
sob
and just run with tears and she didn't
know why she didn't even hear the story
so when i we you know we said well are
we going to vote now and
my husband the pastor said you don't get
to vote
it's pretty clear she's already said
that she wants to do this so give her
the job
and so i i got up to walk upstairs i
picked up one of the sundays on saturday
i picked up the sunday bulletin and
it was january 14th it was the feast of
saint nina
so things like that happen and
you you can just know you get the
awareness of when it's healthy and when
it isn't
and as you were drawn on through healthy
why do we call them supernatural right
uh
what should we call that yeah i don't i
didn't i was like you don't like the
word re-enchantment i never use the word
supernatural
because because it has a there's
something about it which seems like an
arbitrary thing which just kind of
imposes itself on top
of reality uh you know i just i just say
i i have my own way people around what
i'm doing we say symbolism happens like
the idea that the world is full of
meaning and that this meaning is
embodied in
people in persons and so don't be
surprised
when the world coalesces into meaning
meaning because that's actually
how the world exists and so it's not
that miracles
when miracles happen you you shouldn't
be totally surprised because
the world actually exists through these
patterns of meaning
um and so that so that's kind of how i
say it's not it's obviously not a
traditional term
but uh patterns of meaning symbolism
yeah
yeah but you could just say that
miracles happen too like miracles happen
because miracles are not arbitrary
or not arbitrary things that you can't
explain they're rather
the world coalescing towards towards
meaning
and showing the meaning in a bright and
and surprising way it's like as if the
pattern of reality appears to you
in this shining manner and so it's not
at all arbitrary it's it's actually
quite
it's actually the summit of meaning is
when miracles happen
so enjoyable and so fun and so
awe-inspiring
to participate in that like god is
dropping little clues for you
and seeing whether it's like how we look
at children
i think god and the angels look at us
and oh look look she
understood that part this time oh look
she prayed for them
it's an amazing way of seeing it that's
wonderful and that's something like like
we look at a sonogram and we see the
baby the baby has no idea
you know that we're watching them yeah i
think that's what it's like
with the i was thinking too though about
i i only use the term supernatural when
i'm dealing with non-believers because i
know what the word means
um i definitely wouldn't use it but a
cautionary tale i like to tell
um i'm blanking on his name there was an
extremely popular bbc series called
civilization the first mini series
and it was i guess late 60s and into the
70s
but sir something something you know who
who wrote and who
narrated the whole thing he had a
sensitivity
to supernatural things he said when he
went to
there was a certain village in italy
that he just felt evil
he just it just felt horrible and
murderous
he went to the island of iona and he
just felt the goodness
he felt the the good spiritual presence
there well one time he was
going to you know do some filming and a
smaller church in paris
in france anyway and he said as soon as
we walked through the door
he felt an invitation he felt that he
was being invited to participate
in christian faith and it lasted for
several days he said but he vastly
he realized that if he accepted this
invitation
there were things he would have to
change in his life
and between the lines as you read the
autobiography you can sense there was
probably a lot of adultery going on
so he he knew that he would have to
change and
he came to the conclusion that he really
didn't want to change
so he said after a couple of months that
invitation just faded away
so wow you know today
decide who you will serve you know pay
attention to date when you hear his
voice
it says in exodus i forget today when
you hear his voice
respond to that voice you may not get
another chance
you might be like sir richard whatever
and
it would just fade away after a while
it's
it's said that on his deathbed at the
last minute
he became a roman catholic and received
so we waited till the very end
so did saint constantine i guess i guess
it's not it's not for us we'll leave god
it will let god
uh you know parse that out in the end
you know but
he might not have felt yeah we don't
know i i think if we keep choosing
against
the good over and over and over we
become more numb
and less able to hear that invitation we
reach a point where we really don't want
it we really don't want god anymore
so you don't know yourself really you
don't know when you might
just become so numb you don't care so i
think it's important and i
really should memorize that scripture
better about today
when you hear his voice don't delay run
toward him
you may well not get another chance you
may well not
care next yeah once you the next time
exactly
well frederica thank you so much this
has been really wonderful
and for me it i i uh you know
sometimes my conversations are are tend
to be kind of
cold and intellectual i have to admit
but i really enjoyed this this this
really uh
heartwarming and also just helping
people remember how this is connected to
our lives and our choices
and the way that we commune with others
uh so thank you so much for your time i
appreciate
you jonathan you're a wonderful
interviewer you're very easy to talk to
and so if people want to access your
writing if they want to access what
you're doing
what is the best place for them to go
probably
my website which is on the ancient faith
website it's frederica my name
frederica.com
like frederick with an a f r e d
e r i c a dot com and um you will find
all my books
on amazon i have an author page there on
my uh
podcasts going back to 2006
are on ancient faith radio and pioneer
she's everywhere she's everywhere i'm
not too hard to find
but i'm in the smoky mountains my
husband retired from the parish we
founded in baltimore
and here i am at home with grandchildren
around me and i couldn't be happier
well i hope that we have a chance when
all of this whole pandemic thing
hopefully goes through that we'll
have a chance to meet again in person
that'll be wonderful i would like that
thank you john
thank you